albert bouquet bare bow soit je le
disais vous êtes docteur en
neurosciences cognitives psychologue
clinicien chargé de cours à l'université
de paris 8 saint denis vous êtes
l'auteur du livre remarqué en 2019 votre
cerveau vaujour des vous joue des tours
c'était chez alary édition on va parler
avec vous notamment de la pandémie et de
l'un de ses corollaires l'effet que news
les uns fox les rumeurs toutes ces
théories infondées qui se répandent sur
les réseaux sociaux comme des traînées
de poudre et peut-être d'abord un mot de
votre discipline de façon très simple
les neurosciences cognitives
ça consiste en quoi bonsoir neuroscience
cognitive c'est d'études pour faire
simple c'est l'étude fonctionnelle du
cerveau c'est-à-dire lieu d'étude dont
il ya plusieurs types de neurosciences
les neurosciences fondamentales qui
étudient vraiment les nerfs comment ça
marche les synapses et il ya des
neurosciences computationnelle et des
neurosciences cognitives sait comment
est ce que le cerveau fonctionne d'un
point de vue fonctionnel c'est à dire
comment est ce que je perçois le monde
comment se former une opinion comment
est ce que je ressens une émotion quel
est le lien entre le sommeil
l'héritabilité c'est vraiment la
fonctionnalité du cerveau d'un point de
vue de comment ça marche
justement comment est ce que je perçois
le monde vous dit on ne voit pas le
monde tel qu'il est mais plutôt tels que
nous sommes qu'est ce que ça veut dire
en fait mais ça veut pas dire la
première chose c'est que ça ne veut pas
dire que le réel n'est pas important
mais le réel à des marges d'ambiguïté
d'incertitude par exemple la ico vite
l'incertitude est beaucoup plus grande
que si maintenant je me lève et je pars
c'est un peu moins ambiguë plus une
situation est ambiguë et plus on peut
l'interpréter
selon nous à priori selon moi même et
donc jeu on peut dire qu'on peut voir le
monde tel pas tel qu'il est plutôt tels
que nous sommes
et je rajouterais vraiment c'est
dépendant de combien est-ce que la
situation est ambiguë ou incertaine en
sachant que beaucoup de situations sont
beaucoup plus ambigu que ce qu'on croit
en gros on est toujours en train de un
peu un peu reconstruire le monde est
toujours en train de l'interpréter avec
notre cerveau et qui nous savons
absolument j'irai même plus loin on
n'est jamais en train de percevoir le
monde tel qu'il est on est tout le temps
en train de le reconstruire et à tout le
temps dans cette barrière c'est de là
que vient la fameuse citation la carte
n'est pas le territoire on est tout le
temps en train de créer des
représentations par exemple mais non je
vous regarde et je vous vois avec mon
cerveau les photons de lumière rebondit
sur votre peau touche maritine passe par
le nerf optique dans les cortex c'est
une image et créer du coup il ya tout le
temps c'est cette distance
qu'on ne peut pas réduire entre le monde
réel et ma représentation avec l'essence
du temps alors je le disais on va parler
ensemble et bien notamment de la
pandémie de coheed et de la question des
chèques news c'est un sujet sur lequel
vous avez pas mal travaillé celui d un
fox des technos des fausses informations
cette pandémie decaux vidal a été
synonyme de très nombreuses un fox déjà
avant la pandémie vous disiez que
l'effet que news elle marche très bien
dans le domaine de la santé
mais pourquoi alors mais il ya deux de
pan deux points majeurs des faits que
newzy à l'effet que news politique il ya
le fait que nous de la santé ils ont des
motivations un peu différente mais des
fois qui se recoupent défectueuse
politiques sont souvent vains pour la
manipulation d'opinion publique soit
pour faire basculer une élection soit
pour proposer un nouvel agenda etc et
dans la santé
il ya le côté un peu politique mais
aussi le côté business c'est très très
lu que l'arrêt de lucratifs c'est très
rugueux lucratif d'inventer des remèdes
miracles pour tout et n'importe quoi ce
avant ça fait des pubs il ya des sites
web entier sur le web où c'est que des
choses qui sont pas vraies mais qui
ramène du clic ça peut être des plus
vieilles recettes de grand mère ça peut
être des choses complètement farfelu ça
peut être de la médecine quantique on va
mettre des mots un peu scientiste pour
faire sérieux parce que ça ramène du
clic et de l'argent c'est vraiment des
motivations économiques plus est des
fois comme par exemple pour que vides
les deux peuvent ces intersections et on
peut retrouver les motivations soit
financière soit 2 de popularité avec des
dépend plus politique parce que le coc
vide claque au vide est très vite devenu
un sujet très politiquement polarisé
d'ailleurs un parmi les sujets qui
croise politique et e-santé il ya un
événement qui a beaucoup marqué la
pandémie dernièrement c'est le
diagnostic positif de donald trump trump
à la colline le président des états unis
infectés en pleine campagne qu'on a vu
sortir de l'hôpital hier en voiture je
crois que est-ce qu'on peut aussi
entendre ce qu'il nous avait ce qu'il a
dit et bien non on ne peut pas
l'entendre mais elle est ce que
justement la qu'ovide plus donald trump
c'est typiquement le croisement de deux
sujets qui vont intrinsèquement quelque
sorte alimenter les théories du complot
oui pas parce que de notre en pl us et
avant en fait il la semaine passée une
étude est sorti chez lui c'est quelles
facs américaines qui
et que le vecteur numéro 1 de fake news
sur la coved c'est donald trump en
sachant que donald trump est un peu
particulier on va dire dans son rapport
surtout à la communication avec son
peuple c'est à dire avant ça on n'avait
jamais vu un président qui twitte autant
qu'ils discutent autant directement avec
les gens sans passé ni par ses
conseillers ni par les médias
c'est très réseaux sociaux donc c'est la
plus simple sur les réseaux sociaux même
si les infos qui existe depuis genre
cléopâtre mais c'est maintenant que ça
vraiment ça se répand dans beaucoup plus
rapidement c'est pas un phénomène
nouveau en sachant que fait news c'est
trump qu'il a quelque part popularisé et
à la base trump utilisent l'effet que
news pas dans un dans un souci de fact
checking mais dans un souci de défense
politique c'est à dire dès que quelque
chose ne lui plaît pas il disait boss
yorick news vous êtes des fausses
nouvelles et du coup c'est un grand
vecteur parce que trump a cette
particularité de communication qui
effectivement ne fait pas ce genre
la vérité c'est pas très important pour
lui et du coup il ya une étude qui a
montré que c'est un des plus grands
vecteurs de fake news sur la couv it
est-ce que ça s'explique pas aussi par
le caractère très clivant de donald
trump d avignon et à son côté très actif
sur les réseaux sociaux
mais du coup forcément les programmes
qui vont partager des tweets affirmant
que par exemple les démocrates l'ont
infecté intentionnellement mardi dernier
on a vu des milliers de tweets qui était
redouté là dessus
inversement les anti tram sont
convaincus actuellement qu'il dissimule
par exemple son véritable état de santé
ils vont trouver une toute autre
explication
là on revient à ce que à votre première
ou deuxième question sur on ne voit pas
le monde tel qu'il est plutôt tels que
nous sommes il ya une situation qui est
donc on retrouve cette ambiguïté à une
situation qui est ambigu un président de
la république qui est supposé être très
protégé c'est le président américain
quand même déclare qu'il a un diagnostic
positif
du coup cette information est très
ambigu comment est ce qu il a chopé
comment est-ce qu'il va qu'est ce qui
s'est passé et c'est et du coup on va
voir le monde plutôt tels que nous
sommes donc si moi je suis républicain
je vais projeté mais a priori mes
opinions sur ça et me dire c'est
impossible que mon héros autre homme
deux jours avant ils étaient en train de
se moquer des gens qui ont la coved en
disant qu' il se moquait de baden dans
le dans le débat lors du débat en disant
lui portent tous le temps des masques
alors que ça sert à rien moi je vais
jamais la voix
du coup si moi je suis républicain mon
candidat vient de dire que lui va jamais
la voir il va la voir il faut que je
rationalise cela et je vais dire ils lui
ont donné
donc les démocrates et si moi je suis
démocrate anti tram j'ai mes a priori du
démocrate etc
je vais me dire mais il est vieux il se
moque de tout le monde rira bien qui
rira le dernier et c'est sûr qu'il va
moins bien que ce qu'il dit parce qu'il
veut se protéger alors que il va pouvoir
laurent moins pire et c'est aussi
alimenté parce que ses docteurs on a
prédit qu'il avait fui le son taux
d'oxygène avait chuté et hydratant et
c'est là on retrouve cette formulation
de plus qu'une situation est incertaine
en banlieue ou nouvelles ou et hydra et
plus on a tendance à mettre de soi pour
interpréter le réel que de voir le réel
un peu d'une manière plus stable on va
dire comme ça pourrait être le cas je
sais pas on n'a pas de deux polémiques
sur est-ce que la ceinture de sécurité
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut mettre ou
pas par exemple ou que c'est une
privation de liberté on a parlé donc de
l'aco vide à l'international bien sûr
c'est aussi une situation française le
sénat d'ailleurs planche en ce moment
sur la pandémie avec une commission d
enquête qui travaille sur la copie de 19
c'est au ça a été aussi cette commission
denquête l'occasion de s'intéresser à
toute la communication qu'il ya eu
autour de cette crise et les sénateurs
ont par exemple auditionné stib et
n'diaye l'ex porte parole du
gouvernement
et pour elle est bien l'un des problèmes
c'est l'acculturation scientifique des
français sont des mots qui ont fait
beaucoup parler qui ont fait beaucoup
réagir en l'écoutant je crois qu'on a
souffert au cours de cette crise d'un
défaut d'acculturation scientifique de
la population française autrement dit
quand on devait expliquer que pour
pouvoir tester un traitement
il fallait faire ce qu'on appelle les
bras qui permettent d'expérimenter la
validité d'un traitement que ça prenait
des semaines et des semaines on était
confronté à des gens sur des plateaux de
télévision ou même à des citoyens qui
vous interroger dans vos déplacements
quand on pouvait encore se déplacer qui
vous disais mais pourquoi c'est pas oui
ou non
pourquoi c'est pas blanc ou noir et
pourquoi ce n'est pas tout de suite
comment vous vous qui êtes recensé être
l'élite politique médicale du décideur
vous êtes incapable de nous dire si
c'est maintenant tout de suite est ce
que pour vous le manque de culture
scientifique des français
l'acculturation scientifique pour
reprendre les mots de six bêtes ndiaye
c'est vraiment ça qui a posé problème ou
si vraiment ça qui
pose encore problème alors je pense que
c'est très facile de tomber dans ce
qu'on appelle le piège de la cause
unique mais de faire de faire porter la
responsabilité d'une situation très
complexe très incertaine très nouvelle à
une seule cause et donc je suis
absolument pas d'accord avec cette
notion de dire que ça tombe juste sur
les sur les épaules des citoyens qui ont
de l'inculturation et encore si c'était
le cas c'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement s'accusent de s'assurer que
l'éducation fonctionne bien et du coup
il fallait s'occuper de l'éducation
nationale peut être un peu mieux si
c'était le cas je pense pas que ça soit
le cas je pense qu'il ya souvent dans
des situations systémique comme ça il ya
une responsabilité qui est individuel
sur les citoyens une responsabilité sur
les politiques les gouvernements comment
ils communiquent
il ya des responsabilités qui sont plus
systémique et moi je suis souvent entre
un nom jean pour moi c'est un combat
très important de faire attention de 7
sur responsabilisation des individus et
d'une invisibilisation du système par
exemple mais non on est en train de on
est à paris on est en train de
reconduire de refaire des ddd plus
grosses restrictions
donc là on est encore en train de
responsabiliser les individus alors
qu'on peut poser la question par exemple
on parle que j'ai entendu avant de
rentrer sur le plateau qu'on disait le
but c'est de de désengorger les hôpitaux
de ce d'essayer de faire en sorte que
les hôpitaux ne soit pas sur bondé mais
par exemple on aurait pu faire comme
l'italie à une réponse systémique et
augmenter le nombre de lits en
réanimation pendant les deux mois
d'accalmie qu'on a eu pendant l'été ça
c'est une responsabilité par exemple
systémique dont on parle pas et on va
dire ah mais regardez les gens ne
respectent pas les gestes barrière
évidemment il faut lire les journaux
politiques qui disent on n'a rien fait
et qu'on devrait augmenter le nombre de
wii mais au final la réalité on l'a pas
fait on n'a pas augmenté on n'a pas
recruté plus d'infirmiers et
d'infirmières de docteur et du coup il
faut tout le temps questionner quelle
est la part de responsabilité sur
l'individu donc sur moi en tant que
citoyens de respecter les gestes
barrière de mettre mon masque de
respecter la distanciation social de me
laver les mains mais aussi derrière il
faut qu'il y ait un travail des deux
côtés où le système est aussi en train
de faire son rôle de s'assurer qu'il va
augmenter les liens en réanimation
recruter plus de personnes aidées le
corps soignant et caetera et caetera et
c'est très dangereux quand on fait quand
on se responsabilise un camp et pas
l'autre où un camp et pas l'autre et
c'est très important de pas tomber dans
cette cause unique c'est un peu trop
facile c'est une sorte de bouc émissaire
facile
en gros les gens sont bêtes et c'est
tout et
et non c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
vous parlez d'un camp et l'autre il y à
un homme qui dans cette crise a bien
fait qu'il ya eu un camp contre un autre
c'est le professeur didier raoult est
avec les aficionados ses détracteurs
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé depuis ce
que vous pensez de ce phénomène on est
sur un sujet très technique dont très
peu de personnes ont la maîtrise qui en
plus est évolutive tout le monde le
connaît enfin voilà même les grands
scientifiques ne savent pas tout de
l'aco vide bien sûr ils comment
expliquer et bien qu'il y ait eu voilà
une focalisation sur une personne et des
camps comme ça qu'ils peuvent
s'affronter de façon aussi revient à ce
que au même principe
c'est une sorte de grille de lecture qui
et c'est l'incertitude de l'ambiguïté on
a un nouveau virus qui arrive on sait
pas grand chose
du coup on a énormément d'incertitudes
donc on peut mettre de soi il ya des
personnes comme par exemple le
professeur raoul t je suis pas
infectiologues côtoient donc je vais pas
commenter le fond de l'eau plus ce genre
d'un point de vue de formation d'opinion
de raisonnement critique etc
mais il ya une personne qui va venir et
dire moi j'ai la solution et j'en suis
certain d'autres personnes qui disent
non on ne pense pas automatiquement on
voit qu'on va créer ce que ce clivage
sais que c'est pas qu'il ya une sorte d'
incertitudes qui exprimait il ya
quelqu'un qui dise c'est ça et les
autres qui disent c'est pas ça donc dans
le discours du professeur raoul tu dis
le début c'est très clivant et que ça
soit même quand il lui il change d'avis
c'est à dire si on regarde ces vidéos au
début il disait c'est pas important ça
va causer moins d'accidents que des
trottinettes et il était sûr puis j'ai
trouvé le milieu et c'était sûr et moi
ce qui m'a ce qui m'intéresse dans mon
métier c'est l'expression de la
certitude et la gestion de l'incertitude
dans le débat public
indépendamment de 6 son traitement
fonctionne ou pas les tirages suis
vraiment pas la personne la mieux placée
pour en parler mais une opinion ne
devrait pas être importante même si j'en
ai une
mais c'est l'expression de la certitude
et quand on as des camps qui exprime une
certitude automatiquement elles vont se
polariser parce qu'au bout d'un moment
de camp d'en face aussi lisait avec
certitude son protocole ne marche pas
après un peu plus de temps ça a mis un
peu plus de temps pour que la certitude
aussi arrive dans l'autre camp les
automatismes entre m un positionnement
de toute une partie de la population
française qui n'a quand même sur le fond
vraiment pas la connaissance de tout ça
qu'ils puissent se mettre dans un camp
ou dans 1 c'est parce que les français
qui se met dans un camp ou dans un autre
ne se met pas dedans
quand sur le traitement mais sur ce que
ça représente il faut se dire que didier
raoult qui vient avec pas seulement son
traitement mais aussi une posture anti
système
une posture de les élites contre moi une
autre posture de paris contre marseille
une posture de les le pouvoir du
gouvernement les labos pharmaceutiques
moi je suis un peu c'est un peu une
figure de antisystème elle que parent on
va dire alors que c'est pas vrai vie
qu'il dirige à 10h et donc c'est un
système à fond mais mais du coup si moi
je suis une un citoyen qui a des a
priori on revient à cette notion d'à
priori ou je fais pas confiance au
gouvernement ou bien je suis contre les
labos pharmaceutiques où je cherche une
sorte de postures idéologiques anti
système
bon je vais retrouver dedans mais ça n'a
rien à voir avec le traitement le
traitement c'est vraiment georges le
dernier truc qui va faire que quelqu'un
va se positionner parce que comme vous
dites on est incapable si on n'est pas
fait des études de virologie d'hydra on
est incapable de savoir se positionner
sur ce sujet mais je peux me positionner
selon mes a priori sur ce que ça
représente
et c'est là où ça va se polariser mais
cela vient de mes a priori plus que de
la réalité un mot sur le traitement
médiatique de l'aco vide
vous dites qu'un véritable expert va
souvent avoir moins confiance dans une
opinion souvent canon experts est-ce que
c'est problématique pour les médias
justement qui recherchent souvent des
experts avec des avis très tranché pour
des débats contradictoires
est-ce que c'est aussi cette recherche
le voilà de débats contradictoires dans
les médias qui fait qu'on peut aller
rechercher plus facilement peut-être des
des non experts
alors ça c'est vous qui pouvez me dire
comment vous choisissez les personnes
qui interviennent chez vous même par
contre moi ce que ce que je peux dire
c'est que je pense que ça vient aussi
d'une vision dépassée de des humains où
on croit à cause d'une vision un peu
paternaliste que les gens ont besoin
d'être rassurés que les gens ne
supportent pas l'incertitude que les
gens n'aiment pas qu'on leur dise qu'on
sait pas mais c'est pas vrai c'est à
dire nous quand on regarde dans leurs
recherches
quand on prend des gens et on fait des
expériences pour voir comment est-ce
qu'on supporte l'incertitude on voit que
les gens si on leur explique pourquoi on
est incertain ça marche relativement
bien est-ce que ça ça fait plus ou moins
d'audimat je m'y connais pas là aussi
c'est pas mon opinion au sujet d'
expertise mais mais il ya cette fausse
croyance qui est très très présente en
tout cas dans la société française que
ce soit chez les politiques
chez les médias chez les personnes qui
passent
dans les médias de se dire j'ai besoin
de donner une réponse oui alors que
c'est pas vrai il ya eu beaucoup on
disait de fausses réponses qui ont été
diffusés pendant toute cette crise
pour contrer ce problème le gouvernement
prévoit la création d'une maison des
sciences et des médias c'est ce qu'il
prévoit dans le projet de loi sur la
recherche qui va être examiné bientôt au
sénat l'objectif c'est de permettre de
mieux faire connaître mieux diffuser la
production scientifique auprès de tous
et c'est un projet qui est déjà très
critiqué par certains notamment par yves
sciama qu'est le président de
l'association des journalistes
scientifiques je vous propose de
l'écouter il était lui aussi auditionné
au sénat
il y a dans l'actuel projet de loi sur
la programmation de la recherche
l'idée de mettre sur pied une maison de
la science et des médias dont l'objectif
serait d'améliorer le traitement
médiatique de la science et ce en
fournissant sur le modèle du sarrians
media center britannique des contenus
scientifiques tout préparés aux médias
des interviews déjà réalisé et c'est
pour pallier à leur illettrisme
scientifique
je pense qu'une telle institution serait
perçue par le public comme une tentative
de promouvoir une science officielle et
aggraverait la différence aussi bien
vis-à-vis des médias que de la
production scientifique à mes yeux
l'actuelle crise appelle un réarmement
scientifique des médias qui doivent
enfin investir ce champ est essentielle
qu'est la science ce qui passe par le
recrutement de journalistes spécialisés
mais aussi par le fait de donner à ces
journalistes spécialisés davantage de
poids face au service politique et
économique
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la réponse
d'ici à mal quand il dit va grosso modo
ça serait une culture officielle qui
pourrait avoir une scientifique au sial
qui pourrait qui n'est pas sans risque
je suis complètement d'accord avec ce
qu'il dit je pense que c'est une des
choses les plus dangereuses et
d'ailleurs ça aussi que tout comme on a
une fausse conception que les gens ont
besoin d'être rassurés on a une fausse
conception que la science est objective
que la science donne des réponses c'est
pas vrai en science toute mesure à une
mesure d' incertitudes il ya un proverbe
que j'aime beaucoup qui disent c'est
juste la science est une mesure sans
mesure d'incertitude est une mesure est
responsable on a tout le temps des degré
d'incertitude la science est quelque
chose qui qui qui une méthode où on a
nos idéologies on a mieux de
subjectivité un chercheur à sa
subjectivité sur les questions qu'ils
posent c'est quelque chose qui est
hautement idéologique est hautement
politique
et et prétendre que la science est
quelque chose d'objectif de monolithique
etc
c'est une posture idéologique qui prend
un hold up la science c'est quelque
chose moi en tout cas personnellement je
me bats contre cette vision dépolitiser
apolitique objectifs de la science qui
n'est pas vrai et je pense que créer un
comité comme celui qui est proposé
c'est profondément maison des sciences
c'est contre ce que la science devrait
être à l'époque conclure cet entretien
on va s'éloigner un peu de ces sujets
donc qui sont au coeur de la qualité
pour s'intéresser à l'application des
découvertes en sciences cognitives dans
le domaine de l'éducation
flora sauvage s'est rendu dans une
comique classe l'objectif c'est mieux
comprendre comment fonctionne votre
cerveau pour mieux l'utiliser et mieux
apprendre regarder ce reportage de flore
sauvages dans cette classe de seconde du
lycée jean jacques rousseau de
montmorency lawrence berkeley mais les
sciences cognitives au service des
apprentissages
environ cent mille élèves en france font
l'expérience déco niklas un dispositif
qui se nourrit des découvertes sur le
cerveau on va commencer
comme d'habitude donc vous allez sortir
vos pc j'espère vous les avez bien
depuis six ans laurence berthier lutte
avec ses élèves contre la courbe de
l'oubli grâce à des tests de mémoire on
va commencer par un petit test sur les
modules 1 et 2 on voit un petit peu ce
qui reste donc on fait une petite pas
grand chose on va voir une chronique
l'asse en fait une classe autour de
laquelle on va réunir une équipe
pédagogique pour mettre en place des
modalités pédagogiques informé en fait
par les neurosciences cognitives fait
toujours l'analogie avec la un peu avec
la médecine
c'est vrai que ce serait
un petit peu gênant d'aller voir un
médecin qui a des connaissances du 16e
au 17ème xviie siècle voilà pour pour
soigner ses patients
je dirais que c'est ça paraît quand même
assez étonnant de ne pas s'intéresser au
fonctionnement cognitif de l'apprenant
mémoire sémantique procédurales ou de
travail dans cette classe on apprend
comment fonctionne le cerveau lors des
apprentissages
on apprend à savoir comment notre
cerveau apprend justement
bah ça peut nous servir par son plein de
leçons voilà parce que ça va nous donner
des méthodes pour apprendre ce que si on
sait pas on peut pas bien faire les
neurosciences met aussi en évidence le
rôle majeur de l'erreur qui aident à la
mémorisation en reconfigurant les
réseaux neuronaux il faut que l'élève
comprennent bien que l'erreur c'est
quelque chose de normal et que l'erreur
ça fait partie de l'apprentissage en lui
même et donc il faut peut-être
travailler avec eux
justement ce statut de l'erreur pour
éviter que l'erreur deviennent vite une
que l'erreur devienne une sanction et
que du coup l'élève se démotivent n'ai
plus envie d'entrer dans l'apprentissage
optimiser les mécanismes du cerveau pour
apprendre mieux c'est l'objectif de
cette coni classe l'apprentissage sur du
long terme et la mémorisation sur de
long terme est très importante
et là on leur apprend à bien utiliser
leur cerveau est justement à leur
permettre de réactiver justement ces
connaissances pour qu'elle soit solide
et qu'elle soit vraiment comment je veux
dire acquise pour du long terme et
utiles pour leurs examens en fait les
systèmes de mémoire joue un rôle
important dans le processus
d'apprentissage dans ce lycée on se
félicite des très bons résultats au
baccalauréat l'année dernière
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ce type
d'expérience il y aquelques il ya cent
mille élèves qui sont concernés par ce
type de classe est ce que pour vous
faudrait les généraliser je pense qu'on
a besoin de créer un centre national de
la recherche des sciences de l'éducation
on a un crs on a inséré nerveux d'un
centre national de recherche
scientifique mais c'est très important
concrète des centres de recherche sur
les sciences de l'éducation parce
qu'effectivement je suis d'accord avec
cette prof qui disait qu'on peut pas
continuer à faire en sorte que
l'éducation sont en grande partie de la
mémorisation et de la restitution
on a besoin d'apprendre à apprendre
d'apprendre à les apprendre d'apprendre
comment intégrer les connaissances au
lieu par exemple au lieu d'apprendre la
physique et la chimie ou bien la
physique et les maths séparé et je sais
pas jouer à prendre un enfant
le théorème de pythagore donc pour ceux
qui oublient c'est un truc sur les
triangles et ligotée nue c'est tout ça
voilà au lieu de dire ça et l'enfant
voit ça et se dit comment ça va me
servir ça dans le futur en neuf s'est
aussi dit à un moment quand on était à
l'école genre à quoi ça va me servir ça
on peut par exemple se dire on va
apprendre comment fonctionne une
balançoire et dans le bas la balançoire
il ya des triangles il ya l'ipo le
théorème de pythagore comment est-ce
qu'on intègre ses connaissances et du
coup c'est très important de pousser ça
il ya une fondation qui avait de la
fondation la main à la pâte qui est
dirigé par elena pasquine elie qui aussi
a publié des manuels pour les profs sur
comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent utiliser
les connaissances qu'on est en sciences
cognitives pour l'éducation
je pense qu'on a aussi un besoin
pressant de créer des centres de
recherche sur les sciences de
l'éducation en france de ne pas juste
importées ce qui se fait aux états unis
au canada risque en grande partie c'est
ce qu'ont fait malheureusement à part
quelques labo encore une fois qu'ils
font un très bon travail en france on a
besoin de ça et effectivement il
faudrait qu'on revoie l'éducation pour
moi et tout le temps le socle le plus
important d'une société si bête india ai
parlé tout à l'heure de déculturation
scientifique
ça vient de quelque part peut-être si
elle a raison ça vient de quelque part
je pense pas qu'elle ait raison mais si
c'est le cas ce serait pas mal de se
pencher dessus au lieu d' encore une
fois reçues responsabiliser l'individu
déresponsabiliser le site comment se
situe la france en matière d'innovation
pédagogique pour vous puisque vous le
dites on importe pas mal de choses du
monde anglo saxon on a du mal à créer
nos propres modèles d'innovation on a du
mal à créer des financements pour la
recherche france il se barre j'ai deux
amis chercheurs rien un institut pasteur
dans un autre institut qui sont partis
on a besoin de plus de moyens on a
besoin d'arrêter de croire que
l'occident c'est une seule entité que
c'est ce qui marche aux états unis ou
dans les pays anglo saxons
automatiquement plus appliquée en france
on a besoin de les répliquer on a besoin
s'assurer de quelles sont les
différences culturelles qui existent
même intra régions en france voir
comment est ce qu'on apprend qu'elle
matière et tout ça nécessite vraiment un
centre national en bonne et due forme
sur les sciences l'éducation qui sont
encore une fois pour moi le socle plus
important d'une société comment est ce
qu'une société
ce qu'on arrête d'après ans drogba
qu'est ce qu'on apprend juste pour
passer l'examen est ce qu'on apprend
pour ce que c'est utile qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est des questions qui sont très
importantes et souvent malheureusement
retombe sur des obstacles économiques
je suis il n'y a pas assez
d'investissements aujourd'hui dans la
recherche française ce projet de loi
recherche présentée par le gouvernement
estime prévoir un grand plan là sur une
dizaine d'années vous vous y croyez qu
est-ce que vous en tout cas jusqu'à là
peut-être que ça va changer je ne peux
pas savoir ce qui va se passer dans le
futur mais jusque là non il n'y a pas
assez
genre si on parle juste que de salaires
un chercheur es payé beaucoup moins en
france où cnrs qu'il se réveillait
ailleurs on passe beaucoup de temps à
remplir des demandes avec ce soit des
nerfs de financement de cpp plein de
formulaires avec plein de sigles et
moins de temps à faire nos recherches
recruter des participants il faut les
payer si on sait aussi compliqué il ya
beaucoup de problématiques là aussi
structurelles qui font qu'un chercheur
passe une grande partie de son temps à
faire autre chose que sa recherche
et c'est un peu dommage il ya beaucoup
de choses à faire il ya les sciences
l'éducation sont en pleine expansion et
il faut surtout pas faire en sorte que
ça se soit dans l'ordre juste du privé
parce que à nouveau on va retomber dans
le même programme que facebook twitter
etc
il ya des grosses boîtes qui vont
s'ouvrir et 10 nm laboratoire de
recherche aujourd'hui qui s'ouvre sur
facebook sur l'éducation à des artifices
gétaz france
sega femmes qui comme moi c'est
important pour moi un pays développés
c'est un pays qui peut éduquer soigner
et héberger ses citoyens sinon il faut
pas dire que c'est un pays développé ce
qu'ils n'en savent rien dire un pays
développés ci pas juste le marqueur
économique quand un pays ne peut pas
éduquer tout le monde
soigner tout le monde est hébergée tout
le monde il faut il faut qu'on l'appelle
un pays sous développé
tout simplement et du coup quand c'est
le privé qui commence à s'occuper de ses
missions régaliennes
il ya un problème et on est en train de
se diriger de plus en plus là par
exemple j'ai des étudiants je suis prof
en master qui veulent faire des thèses
et malheureusement
une grande partie est obligé d'aller
trouver des bourses public privé des
débours ce chiffre avec des entreprises
qui vont leur dire ok vont vous finance
votre recherche mais en même temps vous
devez faire une recherche pour nous
c'est ce qui est pas un problème c'est
les proportions qui sont problématiques
6 et 15 % de boer cifre et 85% de bourse
nationale genre pourquoi pas quand c'est
le contraire ça devient problématique
contraire aujourd'hui on n'est pas
encore au contraire non mais on se
dirige de plus en plus ce genre c'est
très très difficile de trouver une
bourses de thèse aujourd'hui c'est une
sorte d'angoissé et non pour les
étudiants en master à tel point qu une
grande partie ne veut pas faire de test
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de la chance de
trouver des financements
et c'est dommage parce que c'est
important connaît une recherche
fondamentale très forte pas juste des
recherches appliquées alors que le privé
beaucoup s'intéressent à la recherche
appliquée la première chose qu'on va
vous demander ce à quoi ça sert à la
recherche et il a dit ça sert à rien
c'est juste pour apprendre les gens
disent non je suis plutôt bien merci
beaucoup albert mauguio sur cet
entretien merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu
à mes questions